ce matin on s'arrête quelques minutes 25
ans après le génocide du rwanda qui aura
coûté la vie à huit cent mille personnes
tous en l'espace de 100 jours albert
henson jimena avait à peine sept ans
quand elle a échappé de justesse à sa
propre mère autour qui a orchestré
imaginer la mort de son mari tout y est
de ce cv et autres enfants albert il est
le seul survivant de sa famille raconte
son histoire dans un livre coécrit avec
une québécoise et le cir nous recevons
les deux ce matin sur le plateau
bonjour à vous deux bonjour tout un
devoir de mémoire le génocide du rwanda
il faut le rappeler encore 1 25 ans plus
tard eh bien vous parler un peu français
j'étais extrêmement touché par votre
histoire vous êtes le seul survivant de
votre famille pourquoi vous avez choisi
le titre du livre ma mère m'a tuer merci
beaucoup
j'ai choisi les titres démoli au casse
c'est la vérité mammeri a tué mais des
petits fruits mémoire au pas
physiquement mais mentalement
votre mère qui avait neuf enfants vous
êtes le seul à avoir échappé à la mort
hélène si vous l'avez rencontré albert
il ya une dizaine d'années quand vous
êtes allés faire du bénévolat à l'époque
au début c'était ça votre votre volonté
au rwanda dans quel état vous avez
rencontré albert en fait moi j'ai
rencontré un bar en 2011 faisait déjà
deux ans que je faisais des allers
retours au rwanda est bon j'avais quand
même le rwanda était tout fier d'eux
à bublé des gens qui ont été touchés
avait beaucoup de camps mais le cas
d'albert était comme juste déboussolant
il y avait un regard vide
il y avait fait quand même énormément il
avait réussi à façon secondaire y avait
réussi à poursuivre sa vie mais à 21 22
ans il y avait il y avait un peu perdu
espoir un bonheur à en l'humanité et
c'est comme ça que j'ai dis bien
peut-être qu'on peut faire un bois
ensemble ils vous l'avais invité dans
une des écoles que vous avez construite
au monde
exactement mais il y avait déjà terminé
son secondaire dont je savais qu'il
voulait pas aller étudier là bas mais je
voulais juste lui donner la chance de
redevenir lui-même de redevenir un
humain parce qu'ils me disaient qu'ils
se sentaient plus tôt animal presque y
avaient perdu espoir en l'humanité c'est
ça et c'est ce qui a fait il ya passé un
6 mois il ya commencé les cauchemars ont
diminué avait beaucoup de traumatismes
normal je pense donc ses cauchemars ont
diminué il ay ay à retrouver quelqu'un
qui exprime et c'est ça qui qu'il avait
besoin de quelqu'un pour qui il comptait
exactement c'est ça voilà vous étiez sa
marraine d'adoption on peut dire ça
comme ça
oui et depuis le sourire que vous voyez
aujourd'hui quand il sourit c'était
vraiment pas et même le regard l'espoir
en aviez aujourd'hui à plaindre est
vieux il veut il veut aider plein de
gens alors c'est vraiment une évolution
magnifique
vous avez décidé ensemble d'écrire le
livre d'albert albert c'était un rêve
pour vous de partager votre histoire
quel est le message que vous voulez
transmettre avec votre livre mon message
pour le monde est pardonné mais
n'oubliez jamais et c'est une grande
leçon quand on parcourt le livre parce
que on découvre que malgré tout ce qu'il
a vécu alors qu'il avait 7 ans qu'il a
dû se cacher plus d'une fois donc de
gens qui voulaient le tuer il a pu
pardonner même même à sa propre mère
hélène oui et c'est ce qui ce qui est
paradoxal un peu et ce qui est une
résilience unique
puis pendant plusieurs années justement
oui il aimait sa manière un peu par dans
deux communiqués par ce que les gens
disent mais comment est-ce que tu peux
aimer quelqu'un comme ça et puis
malheureusement elle est décédée après
la prison mais lui c'est sa force qu'un
jeu a dit même si je continue à détester
tout le monde à avoir peur de tout le
monde à ne pas pouvoir me fie à personne
je m'isole et je vais mourir
donc il ya décidé de pardonner dans son
coeur de pardonner ses bourreaux le
pardonner à sa mère et y aurait vraiment
voulu lui demander pardon en personne
malheureusement n'y a pas réussi parce
que les décide mais si la beauté de
cette histoire c'est que oui alors rare
et jamais jamais jusqu'à terre
rien de semblable à personne mais ça ne
crée une force et le peuple aussi pas
seulement le ban une force de résilience
ce peuple là qu' une équipe c'est
l'incroyable devant les ressources qu'il
avait en lui malgré tout malgré toutes
leurs heures pour se reconstruire
albert comment vous voyez votre avenir
réussi au futur ici myfit chaibi werwer
cause
au départ c'est au tour de mike fisher
et up to be good even if est donné avec
joe battat friuli avis tu as we will
continue to be myself and my country
donc ils voient qu'il peut se
reconstruire il voit son son futur avec
optimisme avec positivisme malgré tout
hélène vous retourner souvent vous vivez
un peu ici un pied ici un pied au rwanda
en fait j'ai vécu dix ans temps plein au
rwanda à faire plusieurs choses et là
j'essaie de revenir mais comme j'ai
toujours mon clavier montcaret là bas
donc c'est difficile mais je passe
beaucoup de temps à boire encore et
l'histoire d'albert on la voit dans un
documentaire qui va être présenté samedi
le 6 avril donc samedi prochain sur les
ondes d si radio canada telus ont
basculé dans quelques instants avec un
extrait s'est réalisée par alain stanké
journaliste qui a rencontré albert donc
sur radio-canada je le rappelle est
l'ancien merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
ça va merci infiniment et 60 inhumation
belleville merci beaucoup merci
gianni burattoni baïocco matière cocoa
l'imamat et ben hadj yahia un nouveau
discours riche aller